e
et
[Musique]
bien sûr qu'on a eu peur moi je le cache
pas on a eu peur j'aime autant prié
mais francky un jour me dit tu seras pas
encore lu prière locatif seaway enfer
quelques-unes histoire de voir c'est la
merde s'assagir enfin des corps n'était
pas la mère qu'il devait s'agir c'était
plutôt nous qui devions l'écouté
là quand même on a une patte en moins
c'est dire donc on doit tous compensée
par les bras à part
l'autre jambe ça c'était c'était une
souffrance c'est clair
[Musique]
et
faut être en paix avec soin pour pour
traverser sinon les marlins dans la
hutte beaucoup de chance je les fais
bien proprement
j'ai pas envie l'a offert
[Musique]
en 87 j'étais sapeur pompier en corse et
suite d'une intervention dans un bar un
coup de feu est parti accidentellement
une balle perdue comme disent les
anglais est pas perdu pour tout le monde
puisque c'est vous qui l'avez reçu le
pire dans tout ça c'est pas de recevoir
une balle c'est de faire face à son
handicap surtout dans la société où on
vit j'avais 18 ans je suis partie sous
les drapeaux en tant qu'appelé par
l'armée française se retrouve dans la
marine nationale française et sur un
porte avion est un avion à ma roulé
dessus
kim avoir eu la jambe droite et le
verdict est tombé quoi amputation de la
jambe droite
avoir une jambe en moins se trouvait un
ami un frère est finalement devenir les
premières personnes avec un handicap à
traverser l'atlantique à la rame la vie
ami frank bruno et dominique benassi
dans le même bateau et c'est le sport
qui les a aidés à se relever dominique
benassi habite bastia travail chez edf
mais c'est surtout un athlète il est
huit fois champion du monde de triathlon
[Musique]
franck uivi sur son pointu à bonifacio
il est moniteur de plongée sauveteurs la
snsm
passionné de montagne l'année dernière
il s'est offert le kilimandjaro franck
est doux mais c'est aussi l'association
bout de vie
vie debout à l'envers une association
qui réinsère les jeunes handicapés grâce
au sport bout de vie c'est également le
nom de leur bateau la raison de leurs
exploits sont financés magee pourquoi
parce que maggy bolle ça c'est les jeux
de mots d'amputer comme quand je t'ai
couper les cheveux je dis surtout le
coupé pas les pattes pour faire
l'association j'ai travaillé
d'arrache-pied fm on peut continuer
quand on a quelque chose d'aussi grave
qu'une amputation c'est tellement grave
c'est tellement sérieuses et c'est à
vous donc à force de rencontrer plein de
gens comme on a vu aujourd'hui qui
viennent qui dans leur famille sans
qu'aucun et sont protégés sont sont les
rois quoi et quand on commence à
plaisanter avec ça ils comprennent pas
et donc je pense que par l'humour on
arrive à tout gérer votre traversée n'a
été gérée que par l'humour des moments
je me mettais à pleurer doudou mais eh
ben on réglait sa part l'humour ses dix
ans passés il vaut mieux d'être ici que
d'avoir une jambe en moins quoi et on
partait là dessus et ça nous faisait
rire et puis bon la traversée s'est
passée quand même c'est pas si pire et
c'est aux îles canaries que leur
traversée de l'atlantique a commencé le
point de départ d'une course anglaise al
ahram qui va les mener jusqu'à antigua
avec 26 bateaux de différentes
nationalités vont s'élancer et tenter
d'aller de l'autre côté
le 30 novembre après trois jours de
report pour cause de mauvais temps la
flotte prend enfin de départ
il
et
c'était un mélange de joie de peine de
tous et ça y est on est parti pour
l'aventuré et on laisse tout le monde à
terre deux mois sans voir les mois je
sais mais voilà quoi
c'est faux
[Musique]
tous trois heures on voit plus les
autres concurrents parce qu'on est très
bas sur l'eau donc à houlle commence à
dispatcher et là on voit l'île de la
gomera qui commencent tout doucement
parce qu'on va très doucement à
s'éloigner
et là il commence inventaire une boule
elle est déjà bien loin la méditerranée
chérie où les deux corps s'entraîner
d'entrée dieu l'atlantique ne va pas
leur faire de cadeaux mais il faut
s'organiser alors franck et doom échange
de rameurs toutes les deux heures
pendant que l'un pilote l'autre se
restaurent d'or et tente de sa marine
pendant ces premiers jours franck et
d'eau mais en le blues
j'ai fait une grosse connerie il n'a pas
fait exprès et laisser la trappe de
visite
derrière ouverte glos ayez une vague qui
ont eu s'engouffrer dans notre cockpit
rien de mal puisqu'ils electronics a pas
été touché il ya juste une course sage
je pense que le mal de mer j'ai jamais
le mal de mère de ma vie et je suis née
sur un bateau
j'ai des photos je suis dans le couffin
avec nos parents quoi et là j'ai pas en
4d quatre premières semaines je n'ai
fait que net malade j'ai tout le temps
été malade j'ai pas dj pas vomi tous les
jours mais chaque fois que je rentrais
dans la cabine de survie pour faire
quelque chose
j'étais malade sa c'est alors ma
déduction je pense que c'est le stress
le stress de la course tellement parce
qu'au départ on avait dit à tout le
monde nous on veut participer mais
c'était totalement faux avec nous mais
on s'était mis en tête d'arriver au
moins dans les dix premiers un petit
message pour les amputés là mais ça fait
cinq jours qu'on est dans cette galère
colombo millo chluski film
les dimanches se promener avec bobonne
sur la plage horaire des loyers dans les
pouilles c'est tout
mais il en faut plus pour abattre cette
équipe des coups de rame est mal au
quotidien
ils viennent du terrain et avec
l'appétit le moral revient
tu permets qu'on est encore c'est le
dernier on est 20 à me sens pas pêcher
avec et l'espoir de croiser bientôt la
route des alizés
mo ti franck et demi mais une fois
encore l'atlantique va déjouer leurs
plans
pour pas d'alizée juste une tempête
tropicale
on est le dimanche 11 décembre est en
train de dessiner un grain le sud-ouest
25 30 noeuds sous rafale on est soit
encore flottante et on peut pas avancer
et c'est pas agréable
bagad d'être enfermé dans dans la
cellule
ça bouge toi et côté quand vous êtes une
petite embarcation vous prenez du 8 9
ça fait drôle hein ça change des bouches
de bonifacio
un moment le ciel c'est mais en quelques
minutes le ciel s'est transformé le
barreau a commencé à chuter
donc ça c'est pas bon le ciel est
devenue marron et la houle a commencé à
gonfler et est arrivé un orage l'étude
violence du buzz violence et là j'ai
donné des ordres qui a donné tu t'en
faire dans la cabine et une source aucun
prétexte
et là je suppose que toney je me suis
accroché aux avirons et à un moment je
me suis demandé pourquoi je rame et ça a
été violent quoi violent je pense quand
on en sort comme un accident de la route
on sait plus quoi on est les yeux qui
n'ait comme des soucoupes je sais de
quoi je vais en enfer
né le 24 décembre est tranquille joseph
est né le 24 décembre qu'elle années
déjà 1789
ouais 1492 et nous allons bientôt
trouver les alouettes qui c'est de lire
pour savoir ça m'énerve ça nous énerve
ça m'énerve et s'en tenir arrête arrête
effectué avec tom torel la facture on a
pratiqué on est un peu fatigué au mais
fatigué fatigué fatigué fatigué pendant
la traversée
les proches et les bénévoles de
l'association ont suivi le parcours du
bateau c'est véronique la compagne de
franck qui est chargé de leur
transmettre la météo
grâce au téléphone satellite embarquez à
bord moi il fallait que je sois forte
que je vais j'ai ce côté de de redonner
un peu de courage de ex terra de rigoler
de demeurer dramatiser de relativiser je
pense que j'étais lancre quelque part le
lien voilà c est bon avec eux pascal la
compagne de nous mais on se contacte est
aussi l avait eu 12 mai dont tu
demandais comment ça se passe et comment
elle avait senti mais c'est à mon avis
un contact régulier
donc c'est comme moment donné doumé a
perdu son frère qui est décédé durant la
traversée
on l'a on n'a pas dit on
lundi on sait que dans ses comptes
contactez entre nous et on s'est dit que
bon tout ça sont franck et demi nous
avait bien dit que quelques ça il avait
bien prévenu surtout s'il arrive quoi
que ce soit de nous toute façon ça ne
ferait rien avancé de plus tu veux dire
ça les perturbe vrai en plein milieu de
monsieur lé répond téléphone qui se
répondent répond répond réponse dans le
pays et c'était un sketch alliés hôpital
bonjour oui oui mais comment tu vas
ouais bisous alors moi j'ai appelé mes
petites à peu près une fois tous les dix
jours
mais juste pour dire tout ça allait très
bien qu'ils avaient des poissons qui
avaient déballé n y avait pas de cas vu
que c'est très joli que la mer rouge est
un peu mais c'est surtout pas les infos
dire merci à notre table d'accord
non je pense
également sa mégane a foiré
m
donc les inculpant sénégal un jeu
forcément original a réussi
dans mon frère
même si ça fait deux ans qu'on en parle
plus
à binche
rapide flipo chine
c'est bon le brute la maintenance
alors les gens vont se demander où est
ma ce moment là pourquoi vous mettez
dans des galères comme ça n'a pas
l'impression de faire la course
l'impression de dire le mot qu'un petit
bout et puis enfin combat us alignent et
pour prouver que jusque que les
tragédies qui nous arrive c'est pas des
punitions sont des défis à relever
donc nous on a fait ça parce que je
pensais que c'était bien
là pour la voir
c'est possible
de faire une petite loisirs sur
atlantica qui n'est pas sans moi si ça
peut donner du coeur à l'ouvragé aux
accidentés de la vie
nous on fait que suivre l'exemple des
gens qui sont passés avant nous
mais je peux vous dire qu'on se la pète
pas les tout-petits d'un show sur scène
dans l'autre chaussures
ça c'est les batteurs raveurs même pas
mal et le cul c'est pareil norme entrera
parade et la tête le cerveau c'est
pareil et c'est encore plus peuplé on
partait on peut rire quoi parce que
l'émotion était telle que ans vider un
peu de nos larmes comme disait charlie
chaplin
les gens qui pleurent passer des gens
qui sont pleins de larmes
donc je vais te mettre une défense ces
deux grosses boules pour ici que le
bateau ils gardent le cul dans les
vagues
parce que là ça commence à déferler
assez bizarre et a pour moi c'est pas à
ses passagers parce que l'europe at il
bouge pas ça se passe tout ce que ça
vient ni causer faire lance donc dans la
défaite le batteur est toujours dans
l'axé alors qu'on comporte pas changé
parce que c'était catastrophique
une fois par semaine on devait gratter
la coque
donc j'ai fait les deux premières fois
et demain dimanche je vais y aller donc
un petit peu l'appréhension il n'a pas
l'habitude de se jeter en pleine eau etc
donc il se met à l'eau un petit peu
contractées et vu qu'il est à l'eau je
ne peux pas ramer donc je m'occupe du
nettoyage de l'intérieur de la survie
est un moment j'entends un souffle d'or
je lève la tête heureusement ce n'est
pas possible et doom est en train de
gratter la coque mais très prudemment
quoi j doux mais ça va qu'est ce qu'il
ya tu as peur des dauphins norvez
pourquoi gibbons ne te retourne pas
c'est un petit peu plus gros qu'un
dauphin
il y avait une baleine monstrueuse qui a
frôlé d'oumé et ça c'est des moments
j'ai hurlé de rire mais j'ai vu là j'ai
vu le voilà ça ça a été des moments
et pour moi c'était beaucoup plus facile
de faire de faire la rame sans prothèse
parce que je me déplace plus vite sans
prothèse sur sur une superficie
superficie de 3 ou 4 mètres carrés je
vais plus vite sans prothèse si j'avais
la prothèse c'était beaucoup plus
pénible parce que mon centre de gravité
était beaucoup plus haut donc c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a fait lui j'ai fait le choix
de ne pas la mettre
la transmutation nous a permis d'avoir
une force et une faiblesse la faiblesse
on a un moignon un moignon c'est une
partie de notre corps qui est très
fragile
moi j'ai des greffes donc bon avec des
greffes il faut être très prudent quand
on est toujours en contrôle constant en
vraiment en concentration dessus et la
force bien par où on est passé pour
revenir à ce qu'on fait maintenant
on relativisé les choses et je pense que
ça a été une force par rapport aux
autres concurrents
ça c'est des contraintes que les autres
concurrents n'ont pas donc nous en plus
du vent du cerf envie de vomir
la fatigue de perdu deux fois en gère ça
le jour le plus long c était le
quarantième parce que il y avait une
houle de nord reste très très fort mais
un vendu 30 m2
et cette journée a été interminable
puisqu'à un moment en fin de fin de
journée à la pénombre il ya une vague
d'ouest c'est pas nous l'état reste
vague qui nous a balayé le bateau qui
nous a brisé safran et là ça a été
catastrophique et on s'est dit mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait on n'arrête pas de
se faire bastonner et grosse merde ce
soir 40ème jour de mer et ça c'est notre
dérive qui vient de se briser
donc sans des rivières on est mal donc
on a récupéré la survie ghoul doom et
entraînez vous plaît on va essayer de
bricoler quelque chose on a été le
safran j'ai pas çi chalet ni quoi que ce
soit gibbons safran cassé deux solutions
en abandonne on continue si on abandonne
1 faut balancer la balise un cargo qui
va se dérouter dans trois quatre jours
mais dans trois quatre jours moi
j'aurais trouvé peut-être la solution
pour eux
donc on n'aurait pas la référence de
cette pluie cette journée elle a été
d'une longue mais d'une longueur un
incroyable et bon ben on la subit quoi
et c'est là peut-être où j'ai compris je
demandais 3 l'atlantique je lui demandé
soit gentil avec nous laisse nous
tranquilles en vérité non c'était à nous
à la traversée à la vis à vis un nom les
deux parasites sur l'eau frank moore
mise à part que c'est un monument
c'est un chien de mer c'est vraiment lui
un caractère pour il excécrable si c'est
du fiel mais il faut au moins ça pour
traverser l'atlantique
parce que sinon je pense qu'on arrêtait
au carton donc on a eu énormément de
chance et que francky la ste fusion avec
la mer que moi j'ai pas que je n'aurais
jamais et
franck il a pris la responsabilité de
prendre le bateau de l'ajuster y il fait
que le z
il arrive à s'adapter aux situations
très bien c'est un 5 1 millions ça c'est
bien parce que doux mais il faut pas
oublier c'est pas mal et rien à voir
avec la mer donc d'avoir fait le choix
de me suivre dans cette course
chapeau c'est le combien doublé 43e
en troisième jour de lever
[Musique]
donc il ne reste pas longtemps passionné
ligne d'arrivée après cinquante quatre
jours 23h31
franck et dom et franchissent la ligne
d'arrivée en troisième position la vie
les a mis dans le même bateau et de
leurs blessures a jailli annoncé en
liberté une devise qui vont désormais
transmettre à terre dans des choses
aussi extrêmes il ya deux choses qui
sont fabuleuses le départ sur me demande
de refaire une traversée comme ça je
pense pas que je refais
je le préfet
[Musique]
ans
à travers ses sites non ça c'est sûr
qu'on allait chercher des noises comme
ça c'est clair que quand j'en sais rien
j'ai je connais pas faim le boulot de 41
ans avec ses deux jambes
donc je ne sais pas mais en tout cas je
pense pas je pense pas que j'aurai du
sapeur pompier à l'acia assuré qu' très
bien ce que j'aurais fait du triathlon
non pourquoi parce que c'est plus pour
moi pour moi c'est plus dur de faire du
triathlon avec deux jambes qu'avec une
jambe
quand j'avais des jambes que je faisais
du vélo jamais ce me serait venu à
l'esprit de fair ajaccio bastia en vélo
alors maintenant je le fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui est important c'est pas tellement
le courage de la volonté du monde là ce
qui est c'est d'être motivé la
motivation c'est une petite lumière dans
l'obscurité plus et noir plus c'est dur
et la moindre petite lumière la moindre
petite clarté ça vous éclaire là où vous
devez mettre les pieds
[Musique]